I was on our reddit discussion forum
this morning now we have nearly 2,500
viewers and listeners participating in
political discussion on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash read it on track for another month
of record participation this month let's
look at some of the interesting and
unique threads from reddit from this
morning one is about the Der Spiegel
Trump cartoon that they put on the cover
and it's a discussion of whether it was
too shocking and I was interested in
what people had to say about this we can
cut back Pat just to show people we're
talking about this cover that's over my
show you have it full screen very good
this cover where you have Donald Trump
holding a machete of sorts and then
holding the head of the Statue of
Liberty with the tagline America first I
did not find it offensive I think people
might be shocked or not at all shocked
to hear also from our reddit discussion
forum an interesting post about Donald
Trump inciting terror with the immigrant
travel ban despite Trump's claims that
the travel ban is to protect us an
interesting discussion happening on our
reddit discussion forum also the story
that made it onto our bonus show about
an Alaska Airlines flight attendant who
actually saved a human trafficking
victim by sort of thinking on her feet I
really like that story and we ended up
we get stories for the show from reddit
and this is a story that made it onto
the bonus show yeah a very serious issue
and luckily in this case it turned out
just fine also from our reddit
discussion forum an interesting video
people found of in-studio guest Richard
Stallman appearing to eat something off
of his foot during a lecture this is
compelling video i watch this like the
Zapruder film frame by frame and it is
fascinating it seems like at first you
were not willing to watch it did I
convince you to get out you said it was
just so unusual that I did end up
checking it out the must-see and I think
we have one more and the official david
pakman Limerick thread from the reddit
user known as gigantic meaty balls and
it's a nice little poem I'll read it to
you
there once was a young boy called Pakman
his best friend Lewis was a slack man he
said let's start a show our fan base
will grow then Louis left and now the
fans only get Pakman
once there was a smug vegan called Pat
he sees some lettuce and thinks I'll
have some of that he ate a bad lentil
then he went mental now he wears a
tinfoil hat and lastly I know of a lass
who goes by Rachel who voted to keep the
drug war hell she's so anti marijuana it
made her bananas she thinks you should
be locked in a Cell probably the best
poem like thing that's ever been written
related to the show I don't think I'm
that smug am i know your veganism has
not come off as smug to me anyway I
don't bring it up unless it's brought up
by someone else that's true yeah ok so
anyway as you can see a broad variety of
serious discussions and stories and just
funny stuff on our reddit discussion
forum check it out david pakman.com
slash our EDD i.t subscribe to get us
over the 25-hundred subscriber mark on
reddit it's totally free by the way for
anybody who thinks it's anything you
have to pay for totally free